- C'est le coeur lourd
d'appréhension que Sila s'est
résigné aujourd'hui à venir voir
ce qu'il savait inévitable.
Son atelier de menuiserie a été
anéanti par le feu. Plus de
toît, plus d'outil et plus de
bois, sa matière première.
Sa maison aussi est partie
en flammes.
Sous le feu des critiques face
à son manque de préparation,
le gouvernement de la Grèce
a annoncé que 500 millions
d'euros seraient débloqués.
Des aides d'urgence
aux habitants victimes des feux,
mais aussi un plan
de reconstruction des zones
sinistrées.
Slia, lui, préfère ne compter
sur l'aide de personne
pour se refaire.
L'île d'Eubée, la deuxième
plus grande de Grèce
après la Crête, compte pour plus
de la moitié des plus de 90 000
hectares partis en fumée depuis
le 29 juillet.
Le havre montagneux et boisé
n'est plus que désolation.
L'odeur persistante de fumée
enveloppe les pinèdes calcinées.
Une couche de cendres tapisse
le sol aride.
Une canicule pareille,
la Grèce n'en avait pas connu
depuis trente ans. Avec la
sécheresse exceptionnelle,
elles ont alimenté le brasier
impitoyable.
Après neuf jours de lutte
acharnée, les différents foyers
d'incendie commencent à être
maîtrisés, mais les cendres
fument toujours, des milliers
de petits feux qui menacent
de devenir grand.
Et quand tout ce qui peut
brûler semble être réduit
au charbon, les flammes n'ont
pas dit leur dernier mot.
Les aiguilles de pin
et les buissons assoiffés par
la chaleur nourrissent la bête.
C'est précisément ce genre
de situations que les pompiers
grecs et étrangers veulent
éviter à tout prix. Un simple
feu de paille qui, en un seul
instant, se transforme
en flammes vives et menaçantes
pour les habitants.
Selon les prévisions
des scientifiques du Système
européen d'information
sur les incendies de forêt,
la situation ne s'améliorera
pas, pas vraiment, tant que
la Grèce ne sera pas soulagée
par de la pluie.
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard
Radio-Canada, sur l'ile
d'Eubé